hey how are you I'm really well how are
you that's a good strategy we don't want
to spend our entire second Club on the
free so what do you want to do in our
time here I think I balanced it all by
not judging myself too harshly I think
that's really where it starts and stops
I think way too many people have lost
the work-life balance before it even
started because they're gonna be
critical on themselves regardless of it
right it's so hard to balance and so for
me I just know I'm doing the best that I
can and if I'm doing the best that I can
then in itself has put me in a position
to succeed and some days that means that
I have to choose my family time at a
Friday night or Sunday morning an
executive ran into me on Saturday and
asked me to meet for coffee and wanted
to jam and I just couldn't you know I
couldn't cuz of the family time right
and so that's the family being chosen
other times I'm you know flying and
speaking somewhere or meeting having a
big meeting and I'm missing you know
some sort of like school function that I
don't want to miss and that's the other
way and the truth is I just don't beat
myself up all of us are trying the best
we can and so as long as that you know
nothing is glaring and to me glaring is
the following my kids have become
completely horrible people that have
major problems in society and
I go directly out of business and my
businesses as long as neither one of
those are happening I think it's gonna
be okay and so I think it's how you
judge how you're balancing way more than
the reality of it and recognizing that
you have a different point of view on it
then you're a partner then the kids then
your business associates and I think you
need to care about your point of view on
it first and foremost while being
empathetic to everybody else's points of
view that's the game right like that's
like like everybody could be failing at
work-life balance if they've decided
they're failing at worth like balance so
as long as you know you're not as long
as your spouse or your partner isn't
saying I want to break up or get a
divorce and as long as your kids aren't
like eating pine tar and as long as your
you know banks aren't coming to
foreclose your business you're gonna be
okay you know and I think people are
freaking out like that means see my dad
until I was 15 and I love them and we
have the best relationship like there
are people who've had their fathers walk
out on their family and they didn't seem
for 15 years and now they've great
relationships because they've reconciled
like people are way too judgmental and
overanalyzing work-life balance in
today's modern PR society and so if you
feel good about it then you'll win and I
think not judging yourself too harshly
because it is hard to balance everything
cuz that's life and I'm just I just I
don't aim for perfect I'm not interested
in perfect it's not real perfect is fake
and so I just live you're welcome it
feels better right like it's like it
feels better to like look at it that way
they're tougher than you think how old
are they really tell me anything you
remember being three
right and and you know what when you
really like like as long as you're
counterbalancing it with love and you
know one of the biggest things I you
know all these parents judging people
meanwhile they're around because they
work 9:00 to 5:00 but if they're not
deploying love and are in it from 5:00
to 9:00 every night and on the weekend
what are they really accomplishing just
cuz you're there doesn't mean you're
there yes and sometimes you know most
the time it works out but sometimes it
does it right like sometimes I can get
distracted and I'm just not willing to
beat myself up if I decided to go down a
rabbit hole for an hour on a Sunday when
I should have been all in on the family
that's just gonna happen like I just
this is about not beating yourself up
and knowing where your intent and your
efforts are and also knowing life's a
long game so in two three years when I'm
taking my kids on business trips and
traveling with them and showing them the
world like that's where the benefits
have come from some of the sacrifices I
don't know I think everybody you know if
they have the option of winning would
you rather have had your parents around
every minute from one to five but not be
able to do all these amazing experiences
with them from 11 to 18 versus the
alternative I just have a funny feeling
all of us would raise our hand and
saying I'll take that 11 to 18 [ __ ] and
I plan on dominating that and some of
the sacrifices I have to create between
one to eight is something I'm willing to
do and that's my strategy and I don't
give a [ __ ] if some parenting blogger
says that I'm not spending enough time
with them [ __ ] you but let me come in
any place let me come and judge you from
afar you know what I mean Matt you're
like
but I really appreciate you taking the
time in fact I was running from my
daughter's dance lesson with her
yesterday as I'm commenting on your post
and hashtagging and I got home and my
family was like I get to talk to Gary
Vee in my head was like I don't know
he's like what's that up listen honestly
and thank you right now I'm feeling
really good in my stomach because I knew
I wanted to do this 60s I want you know
I figured out my health by tricking
myself into a system where I was
accountable to somebody else I knew that
I wanted to do something more for my
community even though that I feel like
I'm at the top of the game I wanted to
be better than my best self and I needed
to trick myself into a game that made me
bring more and at this moment right now
I'm super happy I've never been happier
about this 60s you know the 60-second
Club is fun cuz it's fun to see how many
comments and you get in this crazy and
that's all fun but this chat made it
better take care of Oh bye that was
162nd Club gotta trick yourself
[Music]